à versailles l'office national des
forêts observe de nombreux changements
sur les arbres depuis cinq ans en cause
la sécheresse
ce manque d'eau de façon récurrente plus
la canicule on a des épisodes
caniculaires de plus en plus fréquent en
ile-de-france fait que les arbres n'ont
pas accès à la ressource d'eau et en
plus de ça on un deuxième système d'
alerte c'est à dire qu'ils vont arrêter
de transpirer pour éviter de perdre de
l'eau par leurs feuilles
conséquence directe la chute des
feuilles sur le sommet des arbres et
sans feuilles l'arbre ne peut pas
croître et fabriquer sa sève tout
doucement l'art va mourir donc si ça
serait peut être régulièrement un sujet
sain un arbre s'en va pouvoir accepter
une année voilà c'est une année de
disette entre guillemets mais si ça se
reproduit chaque année mais il va pas
pouvoir grandir il va pas pouvoir
s'alimenter et donc la phase terminale
c'est malheureusement la mort du sujet
la situation inquiète les forestiers il
observe les arbres et tente de chiffrer
le pourcentage d'impôts dépérissants et
leur évolution
donc seules les feuilles basses on voit
ici là sont ouvertes sont encore verte
pour certaines ont commencé voilà
commencé à dépérir ça commence tout
doucement et puis ensuite la feuille est
complètement marre ont ensuite celle
ramos donc quand on monte en haut on se
rend compte qu'on a de moins en moins de
feuilles et puis des rames en
complètement sec c'est à dire que cet
individu là et condamné est dans sa
phase descendante et l'année prochaine y
aura plus du tout ça il sera
complètement mort et les dernières
pluies ne suffisent pas parce qu'elle
arrive au début du repos végétatif
il faudrait qu'il pleuve au printemps
pour que la situation s'améliore